Italia five games in a row five wins I
mean you must be on cloud nine right now
no I am I am extremely happy
um my game today was very interesting
not only is big game of friend but she's
obviously a very strong player and I was
playing with black too so this just for
me it's a great result and how did you
look at this game were you thinking
about uh you being in a must-swim
situation
given that you have to catch up with the
leaders so I think technically I was in
a most win situation I was trying not to
think about it too hard just in case
that let's say I get an equal position I
wouldn't mess it up trying to fight for
something else
um but I'm glad that in the game I did
have a lot of opportunities and
um the positions were actually complex
so they gave me some chances and I was
very happy when I realized that let's
talk about the game it was quite an
interesting uh grew felt and that is
your specialty uh Talia tell us a bit
about this position the thing is I think
it's also being
this also I wasn't so sure if this was
my best option but I was placed with the
position I had I wasn't entirely sure
um how to handle it but I'm not used to
seeing the position with the Knight on
E2 and the opponent E4 and I feel like
that's perhaps a slightly better and I
don't need two and the port only four
the one only four like based on some
transpositions but yeah
um so I thought that this would be fine
and overall the way that the game
continued I felt like I was doing okay
especially after F4 I felt like my
position was beginning to get
comfortable and her pieces I wasn't
super sure where they were going to go
um and after Knight F3 Rook d8 Queen E2
I felt like my position was really nice
so
um this is an interesting moment after
okay one uh you know sometimes
you are thinking during the game and
you're like okay if I win this game I
have to explain my move and that's a big
problem
right
um no the thing is that I honestly just
had no idea what to do and I really
enjoyed how my pieces were in this
position because the bishop 185 stops
94.95 ideas so originally I wanted to
play something like Bishop to H3 but I
didn't want to allow that plan right
before Knight C5 right it does make
sense because it's a good Bishop but at
the same time I wasn't so sure if I
wanted to allow something like take
States and 94 or even 9g 594 something
like that but
um
yeah so I was happy with how my pieces
were right now and I thought okay maybe
she wants to play Knight g594
um and that's one of the other two
houses so you wanted to stop that right
H6 it's just I honestly had no idea what
to do in that position and here I felt
like I needed to also just
have some sort of action in the position
I was worried that I would let
um whatever Advantage I had slip but and
why to stabilize get the Knight to E5
and things like that so Green Bay five
was a military consider I don't think I
can trap the queen
in any way it almost looks like after
Bishop D3 Queen before and they have
something but I don't think I do
um like she can
um probably just maybe get the night out
of the way yeah let me see three back so
for example
um
but after Queen Bay Fire I wasn't so
sure what I was going to do probably
Knight D5 I was thinking either one of
them
um and then just see how how the game
was just a normal video game position
right after this one but she played this
move rook fd1 and allowed you this very
nice transition
attacking the queen place the queen on a
bad square and now tie this idea of
Knight to D3 and pick up the exchange if
she goes Rook to C1
how fast did you spot this idea I had
this idea in mind I just wasn't sure
which variation of it was the best
um
so original I was thinking about instead
of Bishop C2 playing C5 right away but
then I felt like the bishop on C2 can
block the C file in case haruko is there
and
um The Rook you know it's a lot better
than the one than F1 so might as well
put it there absolutely and it was the
right decision indeed and it just felt
like her pieces went
um super coordinated for example her
Bishop doesn't have many squares to go
to
um and I was just hoping I wasn't sure
what was happening but I was just hoping
that you know there would be something
for me and I think tactically there is
after this sequence and I think her last
chance was to go to A4 did you consider
this move I didn't consider at all but I
assume that after Knight takes it's like
85 and try to play this position I see
oh wait the in in the game when I had
the Knight on D3 I do have some Knight
B2 ideas and I was considering them yes
but it's funny how here there's no
detail yes as well maybe to probably the
best movie in the position
still black has a pretty significant
Advantage at this point but after this
move Knight we to you fully took control
of the game and I never let go of the
advantage Talia congratulations
um five wins in a row and tomorrow
you're actually facing Jennifer you how
are you going to approach this game is
that a must win game are you playing for
that Championship are you starting to
dream yeah I think at first you know
especially because last year I didn't
have such a great score I finished like
seventh something along those lines um I
was just hoping to get top three in this
event but now my chances get more and
more realistic by the round so I'll just
see what happens
um obviously I want to win
but so did Jennifer yesterday in the
interview so I have to be careful with
um how I handle things
um but yeah it would be amazing if I can
win guys any questions oh
congratulations
you know literally but I really like how
Thailand was coming every day she was
I'm glad I'm happy today I'm extremely
happy I mean it's like I want three
games I feel good yeah okay all the best
of luck for you tomorrow I mean you
deserve where you should be now and it's
really interesting to see the fight
between YouTube Jennifer and Salem
absolutely really good luck tomorrow uh
well done tell you